to say i can't believe this it is
consistently running at 63 watts
bravo amd and asus for giving us this
level of performance
in a machine like this for this price
this video is sponsored by squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
we all know that apple's m1 ships have
been absolutely destroying
intel lately but they're not the only
ones in the game
amd has really been stepping it up and
they put out a claim
saying that their new 5000 series is the
fastest
mobile processor so we are going to put
that claim to the test today
and compare that brand new amd chip in
this brand new g14
zephyrus against the m1 macbook pro
and not only are we going to take a look
at cp performance both for simple tasks
and heavy workloads and benchmarks but
we're also going to take a look at
real world tests such as photo editing
video editing
browser speeds and more and along with
that we're going to be testing out how
hot these machines get
we're going to pull out our thermal
camera we're going to listen to the fan
noise so this is going to be
one interesting comparison now before we
jump into those performance tests i have
to quickly share
a few key differences between these
machines
as you guys can see they are much
different the macbook pro
is a thin and light ultra book it does
have a single fan
whereas the g14 is much thicker it is
much heavier it has vents
all around it props itself up off the
desk
when you open up the display so it can
suck in and exhaust as much air as
possible
so it is a gaming laptop it is not as
ultrabook it is designed for maximum
performance
so it's not completely fair in that way
and along with that it also has this
massive power brick that's 180 watts
compared to 61 watts so it draws a lot
more power as well
and i'm going to be curious to see how
it performs when we go ahead and unplug
it and run some of those tests a second
time
if you don't have access to wall power
now the price of the g14
is very reasonable for the performance
that you're getting and because the g14
is a gaming laptop there's a huge
different focus
on the design and everything including
the display it's a 144hz panel 1080p
so that's great for gaming but it's 16x9
it's not very color accurate the
contrast isn't great
so of course the macro pro screen smokes
it same thing goes with the keyboard
with the trackpad with the speakers all
around it's a much different machine
but we still want to see the performance
differences now before we jump into our
first performance comparison let me give
a shout out to the sponsor of this video
squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website now is the
perfect time
and squarespace is seriously the best
way to go you can build a great looking
website like we did
with literally no web making experience
and it doesn't matter if you want a
portfolio a blog
ecommerce or anything else you just
choose a template and customize blocks
of text and images
it's incredibly simple it's affordable
and r has been running flawlessly for
years now bringing in lots of traffic
thanks to its built-in seo tools
start your free two-week trial with no
credit card required by going to
squarespace.com
maxtec or use our custom link down below
and when you're ready to launch you will
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain the first test that i
want to do
is speedometer web browser test it's
going to go ahead and
test out how quickly and how responsive
your web browsing
experience is and it definitely shows
you the real world performance for
example the m1 max
they are noticeably snappier than my mac
pro
in web browsing and this test definitely
showed it in the past
here we go the brand new amd processor
scored 165
runs per minute compared to 211 so the
m1 mac is about 28
faster or more responsive at loading web
pages
java and everything else that is tested
so it's faster
but this score is excellent this is
probably the fastest score that i've
seen
in a laptop or maybe anything other than
an m1 and now it's time to start pushing
the cpu
i have geekbench 5 opened up right here
and both of these
laptops are 8 core processors that's one
awesome thing
about the amd processors and with the m1
it's also an 8 core but four of those
cores are power efficiency core so only
four chords are high performance now we
also have a difference in frequencies
i went ahead and opened up cpu id right
over here because i want to see
what frequency it can actually hit
because the maximum advertise
is a massive 4.63 gigahertz which is
crazy
and the base is 3.3 whereas our m1
actually only maxes out
at 3.2 lower than even the base and now
we are plugged in all right the g14 is
about done
single core we have 1496 compared to
1744 and multi-core
we're looking at 7322 compared to 7670
so the m1 macbook pro
is beating it out in single and in
multi-core score and just to show you
guys
i do have the machine set to best
performance and it is plugged in so i
wanted to make sure that
these tests were accurate here so i did
some digging on geekbench browser
and it looks like these scores are right
in line with what
other owners of the g14 are getting now
let's go ahead and unplug this laptop
and
we'll see can this performance be
maintained or is it going to tank
let's make sure we're set to the best
performance which it looks like we are
it did go down to performance mode
no longer can we access the turbo mode
and
uh let's go ahead and run this one more
time the m1
i actually ran it unplugged from the
get-go so this is the performance you're
getting
doesn't matter if you're plugged in or
unplugged all right the test
is done and we have 1028 single core
compared to 1744 when both are on
battery
and 6132 multi-core compared to 7670
single core we have a difference of
about 70
that is a massive difference in
performance for simple
tasks so i was curious about how that
big
difference in single core performance
drop actually affects real world usage
so i ran
speedometer 2.0 again and as you guys
could see we dropped all the way down to
112. that's like using a computer or a
mac
that is say i don't know four or five
years old uh
definitely you take almost a 50 hit in
web browsing performance now i'm gonna
run the compute
test built into geekbench five we're
using cuda since that's what nvidia uses
and we're gonna run metal make sure to
change this
for the m1 and this is where this g14
should be doing fantastic because of
that brand new rtx
3060 gpu all right guys there
you have it but look at this cuda score
we have a hundred thousand
two hundred and thirty one compared to
twenty one thousand eight hundred
eighty two it's almost five times higher
cuda performance
that is insane of course that is plugged
in once again
um i'm just curious if we go ahead and
unplug it how much of that do we retain
bam right there that is awesome i am
very happy
of course we did drop performance but
not by that much
looks like about 10 performance dip when
we are unplugged
how the integrated graphics is going to
perform
with this new amd chipset so i'm going
to switch over we're switching over to
opencl
let's hit run alright that is actually
really good and surprising because
that's very similar to what intel is
currently doing with their best
mobile processors on the graphics side
and now let's do a quick
gaming comparison obviously this is a
gaming machine the m1
is not and we have our results and the
g14 has a killer score
of 162 frames per second
compared to 81.1 so basically
double the performance in terms of
gaming at least when we're plugged in
now it's also very interesting that in
geekbench
the g14 got about five times
the performance whereas here two times
the performance
so it's not nearing those levels and it
really shows off the efficiency of the
unified architecture for the m1
graphics and if we ever get some
high-end good games
for mac uh the performance is going to
be awesome relative to raw performance
just like vadim talked about
in his m1 gaming video and now
let's push these cpus to their limits
and see how they stack up
and let's go ahead and get a baseline
reading these machines have been sitting
here for about 20 minutes or so
the g14 is running at 34 degrees
celsius and our m1 machine is at
30 degrees celsius it's a lot more cool
everywhere all around
we just have a hot spot there and let's
go ahead and hit start on our multi-core
10 minute stress test here and as far as
wattage whoa
we're up at 70 we hit 70 watts here
which is crazy the m1 actually maxes out
of 15 watts if you're
counting both efficiency cores and the
high performance cores
and as we're going this thing is flying
and we're staying above 60 watts we're
at 64 right now
and as far as frequency you're looking
at about 3.8
gigahertz on all eight cores uh compared
to maxing out a 3.2 for the m1
now the fans are still staying about the
same and then oh there you go they
kicked up as we're reaching 90 degrees
celsius so definitely a lot of heat
if you guys can hear that from
from running at over 60 watts but i
gotta say i can't believe this
it is consistently running at 63 watts
in a machine like this now sure it's
bulkier and heavier and more cumbersome
than m1
but still a small and lightweight
machine running at this level of power
and the fans are keeping up with the
heat
because we're sitting at 91 92 degrees
celsius
maintaining 3.9 gigahertz that is crazy
i gotta say
bravo amd and asus for giving us this
level of performance
in a machine like this for this price so
it's been about five
minutes see let's look at her thermals
it looks like we're getting
44 celsius down there in the hottest
spot
definitely running hot but still
maintaining that performance and look at
the m1
yep so we're starting to get warm at 38
degrees celsius there
and as you guys see some of the heat
kind of gets drawn back but definitely
a lot cooler and the hot spot is also
smaller
okay i can i can hear a little bit not
very much
all right guys we are pretty much done
here and the whole time the g14 stayed
at about 63 watts which is crazy i like
when machines run at their full
performance
just like the m1 does so our m1 got
finished first
seven thousand seven hundred and seventy
seven points
that's probably because the ten minute
timer ran out and then right after that
it was a little bit closer to that this
thing lapped it of course and look at
that guys
twelve thousand seven hundred and forty
four
points that is insane and now i'm really
curious
how close to this insane level
performance can we get
when we go ahead and unplug this machine
let's go ahead and run that once again
i'm just going to do the single test not
the 10 minute loop
all right they're finished we have our
results and it looks like we got
11 519 uh
which is roughly 10 lower performance
than when it was plugged in so that is
actually
not bad at all way better than i
expected on the m1 we got slightly
higher score of course we're running on
battery both times
and now the performance difference when
both these rn battery
is 48 faster or better performance
for the g14 with that 5900 hs and now
let's get into
some photo editing i have lightroom
classic opened up right here
and this program is not yet optimized
still about six months later so i'm
gonna start out right here in the
develop
stage and these files are massive they
have a bunch of different corrections
already applied so let's go ahead and
shift through these
you guys saw right there the amd
definitely switched faster
try again wow about the same on that one
about the same overall very similar
what about responsiveness if you got a
punch in
very responsive there as you guys could
see on the m1
with our g14 also very responsive now
let's test out the brush performance
this is very difficult
when we're making these uh changes on
the fly
so let's press down all right pretty
dang smooth i'm gonna go ctrl z
try that again a little bit of
stuttering right at the start which
it's just very interesting to see this
much rap performance and it's still
having that little stutter
very similar starting across the top and
then when i go lower it kind of smooths
out
wow all right so so far pretty close
with the g14 being
just a little bit ahead and now let's
really push these machines i'm going to
go ahead and build
one-to-one previews on both all right
bam
the g14 with the amd processor just got
finished
it did end up um catching up and then
going even faster
than our m1 macbook pro which we're
still waiting on bam
the m1 is done and the difference was
around
40 seconds so we had about four minutes
for the g14
and four minutes and 40 seconds for the
m1 so this is definitely
faster but that difference in speed is
anywhere anywhere near
the double the performance that we saw
in cinebench r23
and now let's go ahead and export these
50 images to jpeg i went ahead and
cleared out the previews and i
unplugged the g14 because typically
both these tests they kind of go hand in
hand as far as percentage of
performance difference so let's go ahead
and get started on both
bam we are finished up on both machines
and i don't want to say that i didn't
expect this because i say that a lot but
i honestly didn't expect this i think
you
are not going to expect this either uh
so in terms
of raw performance in cinebench when the
g14 was plugged in we had a 65
a higher performance than the m1 when we
unplugged it we had about a 50
higher performance than the m1 but in
the previews when we built those plugged
in
we only saw about a difference of 15
faster
for the amd processor now get this
with it unplugged when we
exported these images the m1
was actually faster and
it was actually 26 faster than the g14
it took 2 minutes and 40 seconds
compared to 3 minutes and 22
seconds that just blows my mind for two
reasons the first reason is
actually maybe three reasons uh
lightroom is not optimized for m1
yet it's running emulated under rosetta
translated
number two this gets about fifty percent
higher cp performance and this is a cpu
based
task and three this machine right here
has
16 gigs of ram compared to this base
macbook pro
which has eight gigs of ram so this is a
basin loft for 1300 i know i showed in
the beginning
the equivalent uh dif price difference
if both are spec the same
with the same ram and ssd but it's also
running with less ram
and it was 26 faster which
i just didn't expect let me know your
thoughts down in the comment section
and now let's get into video editing the
g14 is plugged back
in and i have a 4k clip opened up right
here the first test i want to do is
stabilization which does use the cpu
so let's go ahead and analyze and see
how long this takes i'm going to start
it on both
both are actually growing pretty quickly
right now
adobe's trying to work on premiere to
get it to work faster on the m1 of
course final cut is king
we're testing cross platform so we're
going to be using premiere
the m1 is ahead we have 45 compared to
65
analyzed that is crazy and our m1 took
exactly
one minute which is really fast and
the amd took a minute and 25 seconds
which
means that the m1 is actually about 41
faster at stabilization which is crazy
and that's with
the g14 plugged in and now let's see how
smoothly they can play back
this h.265 file which most ever all new
cameras are now coming with
uh we're playing back 4k here with two
luts and film grain
full 4k quality and
neither one of these machines are having
any issues looks like both
are playing it back perfect let's go
ahead and unplug
the g14 it is still playing it back
pretty much perfectly smoothly now i am
curious
and i want to see how much of that gpu
is being
taxed yep so it looks like we're only
using it about 30
whereas on the mac we're using it at 91
capacities and let's go ahead and export
this five minute 4k project
we have hardware encoding enabled on
both of these
all right and right off the bat this is
down to under three minutes
of estimated time and here we're at
seven minutes and 20 seconds
the g14 is almost done here and as you
guys can see and probably here
it is just going crazy uh we're using
the cpu affair a bit the graphics card's
at 78
85 percent uh surprisingly it's being
pushed to
its limits and the fans are just going
crazy with high heat
here our graphics card's at 100 cpu is
only at 25
so the m1 is definitely being limited by
the graphics
in this specific test and there you go
the g14
with that 3060 is finished took two
minutes and
51 seconds which is crazy
now i want to run that one more time
while we're waiting for our
m1 macbook pro to finish but i'm gonna
unplug it and see
how it performs now and look at that it
is still
running really really quickly and look
at that
three minutes in seven seconds it looks
like our m1 is
finally about to finish up seven minutes
and
15 seconds so we have a big difference
in performance
there now i will say if we're running
davinci resolve that is
better optimized for the m1 than
premiere that takes three minutes to do
the same test and in final cut the same
exact project same effects
takes two minutes and 25 seconds and
that's the program that's
completely optimized for m1 so there you
guys go
my performance comparison with the brand
new amd 5900
hs the chip that they say is the best
mobile processor against the m1
what do you guys think is it the best
mobile processor we had all those tests
we had real world tests browser test
geekbench
3d rendering video editing photo editing
what surprised you what did you expect
and
what did you not expect i want to hear
your guys thoughts down in the comment
section below
both these are linked in the video
description go ahead and click that
circle above if you guys want to
subscribe and see more videos like this
one
and go ahead and check out one of the
other great videos right over there
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video
you